we would Sandler's kids Bat Mitzvah oh
yeah now he asked Adam Levine to sing at
the box it's that kind of a ballsy move
well first of all five different rooms
like a candy room and then like I'm a
bounce house yes and then like a room
just you know it's like a fake panning
for gold but it's real gold bricks you
can't believe it right Jeff Bezos in a
jet pack throwing confetti around oh my
god would turn into be a bigger event
than I thought what and what out there
are a lot of celebrities there I imagine
I was with your table Oh your precious
Conan O'Brien was it oh yeah I didn't
know Conan and oh yeah Adam and Sandler
man so now they go way back with Marty
oh yeah that's how I know Conan and they
remain friendly yes I wouldn't want you
guys at my kids Bat Mitzvah cuz you
would have goofed on me
no we were we weren't really that goofy
that Knight is goofing on if my mom was
my mom wasn't me so I was maintaining
her and she loves Conan says she's
talking to Conan right and he was nice
to my mom and then we were dustin
hoffman's at the tip so my mom goes oh
oh always at Dustin Hoffman at our table
she couldn't figure it out for an hour
and I go yeah yeah and so it was she
goes oh my god she tells me in Conan
that's a MIDI this is my favorite movie
and then Tootsie's my second thing she
does I'm gonna go tell him we both got
Weezy so calling this once you flip flop
those telling his ego wise yeah she was
oh but that wouldn't be true hey it's a
easy fix
just go in there so I brought her over
oh he was so nice and it made her whole
night anyway
Dustin is super nice again you know
these guys you get him in person and was
your table just to celebrity we had a
really good but you know all the girls
are dancing their heads up with like
glow sticks so we're basically just
watching and waiting and then my mom
goes I think I'm going to tap out right
and uh cuz it's so loud and there were
the music and everything yeah yeah and
she got lupus she's like the most upbeat
person I could just tell it's always
just it's too much so I go I'll sneak
you out of here No and then I was gonna
leave too I go I got a I got a feel for
it right so we walk and then of course
you run into Adam and Jackie right at
the door oh and he goes what are you
doing and I
I was I'm going I was there's nowhere
even a fake like the baths were past
everything the front door I always had
you put in I put in about two I okay
yeah we were they're mandatory to I
suppose winding down it was not so I
says I says to my says yeah I go up yeah
I got it I gotta take Judy each home
she's uh got lupus yeah she's gonna
lupus is really kicking it so then on
thank God for that loop and he goes just
hang on Judy uh you know Adam Levine's
going on right now oh okay I don't know
if she knows him but she's like just
excited about anything
something's happening oh and then he
goes look over there he's standing ten
feet away and so she goes oh we should
stay so I got well I go oh I didn't know
so he goes yeah I just asked him I
thought I would it be you know cool and
[ __ ] Chandler gets what he wants
Jesus and an animal Dean who I have that
brief things with mostly from the show
right I see him we talk about the show
super cool and makes sense he would do
that that was nice so he comes on every
kid is freaking [ __ ] because it's all
girls yeah and it's like what a dream
come true they were like as Beatlemania
they go crazy yeah they know in front of
million phones right more phones than
girls somehow they were just like
everywhere was a phone filming every
second of it he's like this panic around
me